two leaders who say they can do business
with each other
Prime Minister David Cameron is on
famously cordial terms with the German
Chancellor behind the smiles it's
becoming clearer that the two have
fundamentally different views on the
future of the European Union but at a
joint press conference the two stressed
the areas where they do agree we both
agree that Europe faces an existential
economic challenge and it needs to
change if it is to succeed in the modern
world the overriding task of the
European Union today is to help secure
the prosperity and the well-being of its
citizens that requires a more open
outward looking flexible and competitive
European Union today we discussed at
great depth the question how we see
Europe in the coming years and we agree
on many issues there earlier in
Parliament Merkel outlined her view of
the future of the EU she advocated a
strong union both economically and
socially she said she could not support
Cameron's demands for a comprehensive
reform of the block but appealed to
Britain to work for change from within
in order to attain this goal we need a
strong United Kingdom with a strong
voice inside the European Union if we
have that we will be able to make the
necessary changes for the benefit of all
so a commitment to Britain from the
Chancellor but also a plea for Britain
to remain committed to Europe